welcome to stream art makes the
dreamwork
streaming Alex is hard but it doesn't
have to be data flow simplifies it for
you you can start today and you don't
have to be developer we're gonna cover
three topics today how do I start how do
i scale and how do i optimize but
firstly who are you someone with data in
your title data engineer data analysts
data scientist someone who knows that
real-time data is the key to unlocking
new experiences someone who wants to
start using the newest features and
isn't afraid to use some of the products
that we are going to be showcasing today
and someone who might be familiar with
sequel Python and Java are a bonus but
not required
my name is Miranda zere and I'm a
product manager with dataflow
before we dive into the presentation
let's introduce B mid dataflow for our
newcomers beam and dataflow work
together beam is the open source sdk
used to express your data processing
pipeline while dataflow is the execution
engine beam has an open source
programming model by the Apache project
as a top Apache project by developer
activity includes a unified back to
stream model so for folks that are
coming from the lambda world that have
to maintain two different systems
you just have one it offers a unique
flexibility with Runner and languages
meaning you could write your pipelines
in the sdk of your choice with the
desired back-end of your choice dataflow
on the other hand is an execution engine
that runs Apache beam pipelines it's
fully managed and server lists and
system can scale to millions of QPS with
no management and no tuning it offers
accuracy with exactly one streaming
guarantees and offers the separation of
compute and storage with our shuffle and
streaming engine services
so let's get into this how do I start
to motivate this journey we're gonna
take the perspective of a data scientist
named Sarina Sarina is a data scientist
that analyzes data produced by data'
pipelines
she creates and maintains reports and
dashboards and sets up and maintains the
company's data architecture some of the
tools and skills she has include sequel
Python in particular libraries like
scikit-learn pandas map padlet and she
likes using jupiter notebooks to
prototype and explore data ad hoc but
the Serena's tasks come with challenges
she has to run these analysis on a
scheduled basis whether that be daily
weekly monthly and that creates a fair
bit of manual toil she asks you
interface with a number of different
production systems some of which she's
not familiar with and sharing pipeline
code is manual and subject to manner and
then if if data doesn't arrive on time
she didn't have the skills to optimize
and troubleshoot if necessary
Syrena discover streaming analytics with
dataflow but in taking a look at it
she's immediately inundated with a lot
of new information she has to learn
about a new beam programming model she
has to understand what runners are
hearing terms like dataflow flank spark
she's new to concepts like windowing
watermarks and triggers and ideally
she'd have a sandbox environment to test
these concepts enter Jupiter notebooks
which is perfect for her use case she's
familiar with them and allows her a
place to learn about beam concepts as
she iteratively builds her beam pipe
line in a safe environment usually
notebooks have been good for analyzing
batch data sets but dataflow has built
new streaming extensions for notebook
environments interactive beam will bring
new functionality that allow you to
record sources as well as interactively
explore intermediate data
transformations called P collections
this will help new learners pick up the
basics of beam but not only that it'll
help experienced developers prototype
pipelines step-by-step in a read eval
print loop workflow
so let's see this in action
to get started with beam notebooks
Sarina will navigate to the data flow
console and using the left-hand panel
navigate to the notebooks page she'll
see a list of the notebook she's created
specifically with the Apache environment
and if this screen looks familiar to her
she'll realize that this is actually
identical to the AI platform notebooks
interface beam notebooks is built on top
of that platform meaning any features
available in AI platform notebooks is
also available through beam notebooks
she'll click on the new instance button
at the top which will show an option for
an Apache beam VM what this VM will
include will all be necessary beam
libraries and packages for the
interactive capabilities as well as some
examples that we'll go through in just a
moment you have the ability to select
your region your zone a network of
desired desired and once I'm ready I can
hit create that tip process takes a few
minutes to initialize so what we'll do
instead is to navigate to a Jupiter lab
instance that has already been created
for Serena so I'm gonna click on the
open Jupiter lab tab which will navigate
to the Apache beam notebook experience
and what you'll see when you first start
is a readme that includes a directory of
examples we've pre-populated the beam
containers with for examples that
successively build on one another the
first one is a word count that
demonstrates a simple batch pipeline
it's the second example is an extension
of that into streaming whereas as
opposed to reading from a batch data
source it is reading from a streaming
pub/sub topic and the third example is a
more advanced trimming use case where we
are looking at taxi ride data coming
from New York City and then lastly we
have a notebook that shows how you
launch a data flow job from the notebook
environment
so as I enter the directory of examples
and really focus my attention on its
trimming word-count as well as the data
for word count
I want to level set the five things that
Street is really looking for in her
first foray into streaming she wants to
learn five things she wants to learn one
how to read from a streaming source -
she wants to better understand when
doing and how to explore that data in
the context of beam three she want to
learn how to write that to a streaming
sink fourth she wants to see what that
graph will look like that topology what
look like when it's submitted to the
dataflow runner
and then lastly she wants to know again
how can she launch what's created in the
notebook environment into the dataflow
service the streaming word count example
is a good starting point for
understanding how she could do that so
the first thing she'll do is obviously
she will import these libraries all the
relevant ones for Apache beam as well as
some other utility libraries and after
that she will he's ready to start
setting up options to create disturbing
pipeline the next tile that she'll see
is something she's not familiar with
called an interactive option called
capture duration what that allows you to
do is set the data capture duration for
your source recording it can be set in
terms of seconds it can also be set in
terms of size but again gives you the
ability to assign how much data you want
to be able to capture from your
streaming source again given that
streaming sources are infinite this
allows you to a cap for that another
important option that we've also
introduced for streaming data is around
the ability to enable capture replay
what this will allow you to do is if you
only want if you always want to see
these freshest data you could set this
to false so that all the data is new but
as you might know one of the difficult
things about notebook remembrance in
general is how do I recreate streaming
experiments especially
data is coming in all the time the
ability to reproduce experiments is it's
already difficult the ability to turn
this to true allows you to again turn a
streaming source basically into a batch
it allows you to predict on one data
source to again set a constant in terms
of the data that is being ingested so
now that we've talked a little bit about
what you could do with source recording
let's go actually into the meat of this
pipeline and actually start building it
from the ground up the first thing
you'll see is I'm going to be able to
read words from this pub/sub
transformation lndus cell and you'll see
that this read is essentially going to
map to the transform name when I
actually submitted to the DFO Runner the
first thing I do when I see those words
I want to be able to windows those I
want to be able to assign to specific
time windows and as you can tell from
this cell I am assigning them to
10-second windows and what I want to do
with each of those windows is count the
number of occurrences of each of these
words per window and that's what the
next cell will do so now that I've
basically created the first 3
transformations in my pipeline I want to
take a chance to actually now start
understanding when doing and and explore
my data so that's what I have the IB dot
show function this again is a
functionality that allows you to include
window information as you parameter and
not only will you see the number of
times particularly words are being
counted in a given window but you'll
also see the specific window panes that
they are associated with as I scroll
down you'll also see that the ability to
also visualize data that is coming in
through the streaming data source and we
built a few helpful tools that allow you
to converge the distribution as well as
the occurrence of these words in a more
illustrative context what I want to do
now is take that word again I want to be
able to count
based on a normalized set of counts and
not again necessarily count based on
capitalization so what I'll create is a
is a map function that lowercase each of
the words and once I've done that I use
this so function again to count the
number of words that I'm seeing on each
of these in each of these windows and
the last thing that we created is a new
function called collect which allows you
to cast that data into the form of a
pendens data frame and allow you to
interact with that data in a contact
that's a lot more familiar so now that
I've kind of taken a look at one how to
read from a streaming source now that I
understand that when doing is and how to
explore that data and I now get a chance
to do those things now I start to
actually think about how do I launch in
the day of a service and what I'll do
here is I'll switch over to the idea for
a word count example when I click on
this again this is just repeating the
word count examples from the initial
examples but I'll quickly jump into the
interesting parts now that I am thinking
about launching at the data for service
I don't think about actually writing
this data to an output data set and by
you know going through these specific
cells you'll see that I will write this
to GCS after I've specified a few
options you'll see that I've now
indicated a GS bucket which will contain
the output of this of this streaming
data pipeline and once I have created
this out of this write transformation
which will write this to text file and
write it into a specific GCS location I
want to now see what will this look like
on the data flow service that's where
I'll use the Ibo graph function which
will give me an example of what might
apology will look like and then as you
can tell it's exactly as I described it
you'll read data from a pub sub source
that will cast it to a specific peak
collection called words
I'll count those and write them to
college storage but I'll also create a
separate branch which will lowercase the
words and count unique instances that
are irrespective of capitalization now
that I've verified that graph I can now
use the dataflow Runner to run that
pipeline and when I run this cell right
here I can now quickly click here and
navigate specifically to the job that
I've written in the data flow console
and with that
Syrena now has gotten the entire top to
bottom with streaming data sources using
a beam notebook Serena doesn't only
happen to use notebooks so you can also
use sequel to launch streaming jobs data
flow sequel the GA capability allows you
to launch data flow pipelines from the
bigquery UI she can select sources and
sinks from pub/sub to bigquery to GCS
and has a visual schema editor to help
inspect the data some of the cool things
she can do with this capability include
real-time dashboards with bigquery as
well as create other sources for other
streaming pipelines now that serena has
mastered the fundamentals how does she
scale her team wants to you streaming
now for data transport simple
transformation needs as well as
real-time analytics but her teammates
have different requirements they all
have different sources and sinks not all
them have programming skills and they
all prefer to work from different
environments whether that be the UI the
command line or the ninety the solution
Syrena can use flex templates the
feature that we recently launched into
beta with flex templates she can turn
any pipeline into a template that can be
used by other teammates you just can
take that template and execute it with
their own arbitrary parameters passed in
they can do this from the UI from the
command line or by passing in a request
with the REST API
we'll now go through a walkthrough of
flexsim plaits which will show how we
containerize a dataflow pipeline
building the Flex template itself then
launching it from the UI
before Serena can use flex simplest to
share her pipeline with her teammates
she has to first author a pipeline so
we'll start our demo by looking at the
pipeline she's authored this is a Python
template available online that is
ingesting a stream of positive and
negative reviews and as you can look at
the statistics helper function it is
returning URL the number of reviews
returned by a URL an average score for
those URLs and the oldest and most
recent version of those reviews and if
you look at the pipeline itself you'll
see it's a very simple read from pub/sub
a transcription of bites to string as
well as a parsing of the JSON message
itself it windows that data into given
intervals that will slice that data in
the specified window a duration group
those URLs and then run that statistic
helper function and as you can tell
there are a list of arguments that are
listed at the end of the pipeline that
are going to be used for passing in as a
template parameter so now that we've
looked at the pipeline we're gonna use
docker to build that template so I'm
gonna switch over to the shell window
and copy and paste a built command and
what this is doing is building that
pipeline into a container the this
g-cloud command is essentially roughly
equivalent to authenticating into the
docker service building that that that
docker container using the image as well
as pushing that to the google container
registry and once we are concluded
you'll see that our pipeline has
successfully been turned into a docker
container so now that we have it in the
container registry we are one step short
of turning it into a Flex template
before we can do that we have to create
a template spec file which includes the
name description and input parameters so
I'll flip back to my tux editor and see
what this
container spec file looks like you'll
see that it has a name a description as
well as a name label and help text for
the given parameters what my parameters
will include will be a pub sub input
subscription a big query output table as
well as a user specified window interval
as you can also tell I can also create
some validation around whether these
specific parameters are optional or not
so now that we're ready to actually
build the Flex template I'm gonna
quickly copy and paste my Flex template
command and I will go back to my shell
and once again I will use a g-cloud beta
command which was recently created for
Flex templates and build the container
and what we'll see in just a few moments
is successfully saving this container
spec and this flex template file which I
will be able out to call in the UI so I
can copy and paste this directory right
here and go back to the UI so I'm back
in the data flow console and in the jobs
list page I can see at the very top a
button for creating a job from template
I'm gonna have a gate to that and I'll
see that I had the ability to specify a
name so we'll call this Serena teammate
pub/sub to bigquery and I have the
ability to select a template what you'll
also see is a list of Google provided
templates which allow you to do some
very simple things for streaming as well
as batch and utility functions but for
the sake of the example we're gonna
focus primarily on the custom template
if you remember we have a GS location
for that flux template I'm gonna copy
and paste that in here and once I've
seen that I've seen a validate I'll see
that description that I specified in the
container spec file is located here and
the required parameters are found right
here and now my teammates can now use
the same template that I've created
on behalf of Sarina what the
organization - again drive standardize
and more broadly an able data flow for a
streaming organization and in the event
that you do not want to confine this to
the UI you'll see at the very bottom we
have the also the ability to create the
equivalent rest as well as the
equivalent command line so again if you
want to be able to launch a dataflow job
from your own environment you have the
ability to also just do that directly
from the UI and enable your organization
to use flex templates serena has now
solidified her data flow expertise and
she's been able to share it with
teammates the final mission for her how
does she optimize her pipelines Serena
needs various things to help understand
what is happening in our data processing
environment monitoring observability
tools logging statistics and counters
and alerts to know type lines fall
behind or violate their SLO s-- the
great thing about data flow is we offer
these tools right out-of-the-box we
offer a rich observability experience
that includes relevant time-series
metrics logs and configuration
information and we've also recently
launched a managed pipelines view that
help you understand how your recurring
data flow jobs are running and quickly
identify if your data sets are not being
processed in time
so let's look back to the user interface
for our third demo to demonstrate how
we're going to use the new observability
experience to optimize your data flow
job we're going to navigate to the data
flow console the first screen you'll see
is the jobs list page which again is a
listing of all your jobs sorted by type
as well as status and the ability to
filter those jobs we're going to focus
our attention on a retail application
that we open source what this
application is doing is reading data
from website in mobile apps it is also
collecting transaction information from
on-premise systems like a brick and
mortar location as well as collecting
information from inventory to track the
inventory levels of a specific product
and is to join that information in
running computations I didn't click on
that job and as it's loading I also
mentioned that this application is fully
open source so I do encourage you to
look at the source code for this
application for yourself the first thing
you'll see is the job graph the job
graph is the data foreigners
interpretation of your business logic it
presents this topology for you to again
review the entirety of your application
as I've already mentioned what this
application is doing is reading for
multiple sources its processing multiple
streams of data in writing to different
sinks at the very top you'll see the
read transformations you'll see that
it's reading a click stream of data
coming from websites and mobile apps a
transaction stream which is reading data
from on-premise systems for example
premortal locations and then lastly a
stream of data that is tracking the
levels of inventory available each of
these streams have respective processing
buckets and at the very end you'll see
after a a number of different
computations were made as well as some
counts we are writing to a async like
bigquery for the consumption of another
team to run analysis as well as to
pub/sub for consumption by other
pipelines you'll see a little bit of a
little arrow next to me
boxes and what that's really doing is is
condensing a lot of information when I
click on the process click stream you'll
see a pretty significant expansion with
the Nick with an explanation of what
each of these steps are doing again this
is again business on it that's been
expressed by you and you'll see things
like clean data mapping elements
filtering that data as well as computing
account to see which products are
selling the best and then once that that
computation is made right into bigquery
but if I want to get a better sense for
how specific steps are performing I can
click on that step and what you'll see
on the right here is stepper information
the information with regarding to the
throughput of that data as well as the
output collections again you'll be able
to identify specifically which steps
might be problematic and dig a little
deeper from there and one last thing
they'll say about the job graph in the
specific splash page is you have a job
info panel on the right which allow you
to collect important metadata about your
job including job ID the SDK version
location specific information with
regards to the metrics the the resources
being consumed this will have a direct
relation to the cost of the pipeline
itself as well as the pipeline options
if you've selected for your pipeline
we've recently announced a job metrics
tab and this is what we are referring to
as the observability - and this is what
you want to use to optimize your job but
also to diagnose issues that might arise
you'll see specific graphs that are
inline data freshness showing the
watermark of your data and to identify
whether data is following behind for
whatever reason system latency which
will show again if there's a specific
bottleneck in your system you'll see an
auto scaling graph this specific
application is only showing one worker
so if it's not really showing the
dynamism of data flow but if you have an
application that it's looking at
multiple workers with varying degrees of
volume that will also show in the amount
of workers that are being provisioned
for your job you'll also see the same
through program
that we mentioned on a per step level
but what's very helpful about this
specific table is that now you are
looking at the entirety of your job and
now the ability to you know sort your
steps by throughput and then quickly
identify specifically where you might
have bottlenecks in your business logic
you'll see CPU utilization which will
also chart the amount of CPU being used
by workers and then lastly you'll see a
worker error log count which again allow
you to see where specific errors are
occurring on your workers I think
another interesting another good tip
here is you'll see that when I hover
over the chart I'll see a gray dashed
line which will also showcase itself in
the in the charts above in CP
utilization and what that allows you to
do is very quickly draw a correlation
between when an error might be happening
and what might be happening on your CPU
ization as well as your throughput
another tool that I'll also mention in
this is the the time selecting tool and
by default you'll see six hours but you
can actually look back as far as seven
at thirty days we'll just take a look at
informaiton the last seven days and what
you'll see is a varying degree of
throughput just as you would see as a
root application you'll see varying
degrees of volume of user traffic and
that's represented in this graph in the
throughput graph again if you if you're
more prefer to see the amount of data
that's being written in terms of
gigabytes in size you also have the
ability to select estimated bytes per
second and the last thing I'll also
mention is we also have a logs panel
that includes job blogs worker logs and
a direct integration with our job error
reporting tool which will allow you to
do more meta analysis on specific errors
that might be causing a backlog in your
processing so in summary what we covered
today was ways the users can optimize
your data for pipeline using the job
graph job metrics and the
job in worker logs but not only is it a
crucial tool for optimization but also
for diagnosing problems data for
pipelines will always present challenges
due to the shape of data and the always
changing nature of data processing in
real time but the the entire
employability experience allows you to
get that as quickly and efficiently as
possible
so let's summarize what we've covered
today how do I start we can start with
data flow with notebooks and/or data
flow sequel how do i scale we can scale
our knowledge and organizations with
flux templates and how do i optimize we
can maximize the performance of our jobs
with the new observability experience
but note that is only a fraction to what
dataflow has to offer we can also start
our journey to data flow with Google
provided templates that I showed in the
demo for scaling we have shuffle and
streaming engine which can scale your
job to millions of QPS with no code
change required you have tools to help
optimize your pipelines even more and if
you're ready to go take your pipeline
into production we published a brand-new
white paper on building production ready
data pipelines to use data flow yep use
the Apache team SDK and to that end
there are lots of ways you can build on
your beam knowledge base we have ID
exercises called cut us we have quick
labs you have code samples and we have
the retail application that's been open
source the same application that I've
presented in the third demo and not only
that we have a thriving developer
community in the beam world this
presentation will be published alongside
the recording now it's strongly
recommend using this as a reference for
the beginning of your beam and data flow
journey in case you want to check out
what else is new in D Alex we have
dozens of sessions that are ready for
you but if you're interested in more on
streaming analytics I would recommend da
101 easy access to stream analytics and
da 209 real-time AI showing some of our
advancements with dataflow and machine
learning applications
thank you for your time today I'm
looking forward to seeing you start your
streaming journey on data flow